it was a deadly morning on our valley  roads thank you so much for joining us  tonight at five o'clock i'm sasha loftis  nhp is investigating four fatal crashes  that happened in just a matter of hours  the first was near sunset in the 215 on  the northbound ramp there nhp says the  crash involved two cars one person died  the second crash involved a motorcyclist  near the 95 and lake mead boulevard one  person died there as well the third  crash that was in laughlin on state  route 163 and casino it involved a  single car one person also died there  then another deadly crash happened on  the southbound i-15 near lake mead this  was also a single car crash that killed  one person